hey everyone my name is Stephanie  Strasser II with the Kat Von D beauty  artistry collective and I'm here with  glamour today to teach you how to do the  perfect ombre brows using our 24-hour  super brow I just start by at the bottom  and I start lightly doing tick marks and  feathering it up and into the brow hairs  what I like to do is bring it over a  little bit further than I normally would  because that allows some blending room  for the purple take that kind of dirty  brush that already has the pink in it  and mix a little purple into it that way  it gives a really beautiful transitional  color once I've got that on there I dip  my brush back in to get a more true  purple now once you've got that done I  go in with another clean spoolie and I  actually roll the product right into the  spoolie this acts as a second way to get  that ombre look  [Music]  you